ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi è un
giorno senza precedenti un giorno che
entrerà nella storia di cucina bottata
un giorno che dimostra quanto di buono
abbia fatto io fino ad adesso un giorno
allora che dimostra quanto di buono
fatto fino ad oggi nonostante la loro
presenza
succede che ma finalmente trovato
qualcuno che ci sostenga
kimi seguito di instagram già sa che da
un po di tempo ciobar mi ha invitato a
prendere parte a una challenge che si
chiama troppo frigo sapete perché
perché se mangi ciobar 6 troppo fico 6
stringente con voglia di qualcosa di
fresco sei troppo figo ma è un frigo
anzi un troppo frigo in cosa consiste la
challenge è molto semplice ciobar ha
intimorito dalle mie doti culinarie mi
ha sfidato nel replicare uno dei loro
prodotti per esattezza quello
all'interno di questo frigo che cosa
sarà mai
rullo di frigoriferi non si sta parlando
del tuo cervello tranquillo ma dalle
parti di scherzi che cosa c'è stiamo
parlando di un mini frigo contenente i
dessert freschi cio barra
ma ci stanno governi cos'è stato buono
se dobbiamo sbrigarci la prima la prima
volta che non facciano 21 per una mano e
l'altro per lato alla fine di tutto
quanto gli assaggeremo e voi dovrete
decidere quale dei due ha vinto il mio
i ragazzi voi state trovando un lavoro
per 3 2 perché per fare quello che io ho
ribattezzato il bar home made di
guglielmo scilla avremmo bisogno di più
che altro è sudatissima questa paura
pure lei un litro di latte
interiorizzato il latte alle ginocchia
non nemmeno amido di mais
showcolate latte condensato junker o una
caccola de burro quello che voglio fare
in questa sfida è valutare sia il gusto
che la velocità
se devo combattere contro il gesto di
andare al supermercato prendere una
vaschetta e tornare a casa
deve riuscire a fare una cosa molto
molto veloce perché sennò avrei battuto
anche solo sui tempi che mi sto sentendo
grembiule per l'occasione mettiamo il
vestito elegante in grembiule che tra
valente se non so se leggete ma è paul
frank ma partiamo quindi con il
procedimento in una ciotola prendiamo il
litro di latte e c'è lo buttiamo dentro
che per alcuni e ci stai a caldo di
mucca poi veloci aggiungiamo l'amido di
mais cioccolato abbiamo tutto
fondamentale oddio santo di zucchero
del latte condensato sono le cose che
sono sia cattive che buone allo stesso
tempo non so se c'è ed è presente in
uscita la prossima volta mi faranno non
ci sarà una prossima volta sciacca manca
la casacca destinazione dovevo piazzando
sul fuoco
la salvezza ma ogni fronte troppo più
non sono troppo prima dovesse avere più
o meno questa possibilità che con un
frullatore a immersione andremo a
rendere più omogenea ricordo degli animi
cucina e per favore
ottimo
che visse con figo avete cercato di
pregare la persona sbagliata
[Risate]
però non è bellissimo questo ragazzino
tu su quali basi ed è uguale fa dalle
micro tra i fornelli
nessuno dovrebbe funzionare così ora che
se funziona vedere altri che ti prendi
si vive
valuterei bene in questa scelta ragazzi
e
ovviamente deve cucinare ancora là
dentro però danno il secondo cioè a
quest'ora sui fornelli ci mettevano più
tempo fidati giammarco e l'amore
platonico per la disoccupazione a
ragazzi tutto questo non so se avete
visto queste meravigliose calamità tra
quali andranno chieste al lucro da
esporre vicino alla monna lisa però non
lo so lei non se la sentiva tanto paura
del confronto con regione una chiamata
da tim brown che un po ha rosicato
perché un po di anni fa avrebbe scritto
al posto del codice da vinci il codice a
barre con con il mio avviso è il morto
invece che stare come l'uomo di vitruvio
stava cibo tra un po frivolo precederci
zione nascosta qua dentro
facciamo che questi altri due minuti
proprio non portano a niente
l'aria è stata tina fosse fuoco si è
riservata manca una tua calamità qua
sopra
tre immagini così quella che basta che
ti iscrivi al sito bartram spediscono
cioè così grande
ed etico per entrarci dentro sette ore
dopo stiamo ancora così a nostra
facessimo qua
sì ma tu sei ossessionato il fuoco
ossessionato con i fornelli un piromane
in cucina ma ragazzi sta bruciando
ragazzi si sta bruciando ragazzi si sta
bocciando assiste ben salda ma c'era
puzza di bruciato
forse loro forse è un po è un po
bruciato se non appaia grattare il fondo
il bruciato dovrebbe rimanere sotto
mamma mia che mi macello sui forni
riguarda la allora posso dire una cosa a
degli strani pezzi nominato c'è
praticamente ho messo e questo
nell'acqua per cercare di raffreddarlo
più velocemente ma l'acqua era troppo e
quindi entrato dentro ci sta e sempre
cremoso
queste sono stato un po di sfortuna
perché secondo renderà stanno tirando
sta venendo benissimo eccellenti che hai
buone probabilità di vincere la sfida
prendiamo uno di questi mettiamo il
composto in ciotoline più piccoli in
modo da raffreddarlo più velocemente
passati 40 anni
andiamo a prendere la crema per farvi
assaggiare una crema meravigliosa una
crema q bar
diamogli una sbattuta in modo da
amalgamare tutto ragazzi del momento
dell'assaggio così è un pro forma
possiamo dirlo perché cioè si capisce
già i 32 è il vincitore si vede tutti i
ragazzi sono simili alla fine
e allora dice barra prima quella sì
perché così prima un sapore un pochino
meno gradevole e poi invece questo
giallo mangiato e realtà quindi la
colonna che dire mediocre buona buona
fredda calda piedi da
gradevole si avvicina agli standard c'è
il colore
ma la dei grumi
cos'è le pepite di padelle da
rinfacciare su re ha assaggiato
passaggio ma fidatevi
no no no no no parco deve essere ma che
vedrete fi simpatici questa vita anche
il popolo abbastanza nauseante superiore
non sono grumi sono delle schegge di
affumicato e secondo me danno un gusto
interessante rispetto al quadro sapere
questa bella varietà forse non l'ho
mangiata con l'acqua
ora facciamo il confronto tra i due ci
sarà un vincitore
ok della fascia chiamiamola troppo frigo
e quel vincitore lo si voterà mettendo
il proprio cucchiaino davanti quindi la
domanda è chi vince tra la crema fresca
di guglielmo o quella di smart 321
votammo ok
siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
se volete prendere anche voi parte a
quest'iniziativa iscrivetevi nel sito
ciobar provato a vincere la vostra
calamità personalizzata come sempre
invito a mettervi un bel pollice su per
il qualora vi sia piaciuto questo video
iscrivervi al canale ma soprattutto
attivare la campagna delle notifiche se
non volete così dormire con un occhio
sul telefono per sapere quando uscirà un
nuovo video sul canale io vi mando un
bacio ci vediamo la prossima domenica
sempre alle 12 con cucina buttata ciao
la stretta secondo me sarebbe diversa